hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute mal wieder einen
richtig leckeren sonntagskuchen machen
und zwar gibt's einen marzipan
streuselkuchen mit kirschen und dieser
streuselkuchen ist ganz einfach denn wir
werden jetzt gleich nur einen teig
herstellen
das ist dann sowohl der teig für unter
die kirchen als auch also das ist
praktisch ein streik den man sich für
unten und eben auch für oben und ich
zeige euch auch direkt die zutaten und
dann geht es direkt los
ich brauche 300 gramm marzipanrohmasse
die es jetzt kalt aus dem kühlschrank
350 gramm mehl 150 gramm zucker eine
prise salz ein ei und 225 gramm weiche
butter und dann habe ich für die füllung
hier bereits 400 gramm sauerkirschen 50
milliliter saft das ist auch ein saurer
kirschsaft hier habe ich zwei gehäufte
esslöffel stärke und ich brauche noch
ein esslöffel paniermehl jetzt geht's
auch direkt los am besten nimmt da
einfach ein mixer oder ihr macht es eben
mit den händen zu essen smart fan grob
raspeln
das macht das jetzt in der maschine aber
ihr könnt auch seine küchen reibe
benutzen
und jetzt mache ich auch direkt da oben
weiter und geht jetzt einfach noch die
anderen zutaten mit rein
erst mal nur ein bisschen mehr ich gebe
dann zum schluss mama hat das mädel dazu
und euch bestimmt aufgefallen ich habe
keine vanille extrakten aber ich finde
einfach so einen eigenen tollen
geschmack und deswegen belassen wir es
bei diesem maß panaroma heute kennen so
etwas salz dann ein ei für die bindung
und stiefmutter und ich habe meinen teil
schon vergessen
und jetzt wird es alles schön vermixt
und dann gebe ich auch gleich noch das
remis mit dazu
märz gut aufgepasst hat der wird gemerkt
haben dass ich vergessen habe dass mixa
einzusetzen
und dass deswegen gerade entgegen ich
hab nämlich angemacht und das hört
einfach nicht
aber es liegt halt daran dass kann mixa
drin steckt aber jetzt muss ich ganz
kurz die streusel maße um film damit
dass mixa einsetzen kann und es dann
eben vermissen kann also das dürfte
nicht vergessen
ich habe mir selbst gezweifelt
mixa rein oder er macht den streusel
dann die streusel dann eben einfach mit
den händen weiter oder mit einem
handrührgerät mit knie tagen das geht
auch aber ich mache das jetzt eben kurz
da drin
jetzt würde ich das tier kurz rein und
vermengen dann noch das restliche mehl
mit da rein
jetzt hatte ich hier eine springform mit
dem durchmesser von 24 zentimetern
ihr könnt aber auch im springen war mit
26 nehmen dann wird der kuchen etwas
flacher und eben nicht so ganz hoch und
die fertig jetzt einmal kurz ein
mit back trance trail könnte aber auch
butter und mehl benutzen
und da gebe ich jetzt zwei drittel von
dieser streusel masserey
das drücke ich es schön flach und form
am rand noch sondern 2 bis 3 cm hohen
rand
da können dass euch bisschen einfacher
machen wenn ihr mehr über schreibt dann
klebt es auch nicht an den händen an
den teig kurz in den kühlschrank
gestellt werden der zwischenzeit schon
mal die füllung vorbereiten und zwar
gebe ich jetzt den saft in einen kleinen
topf und ihr könnt ihr auch stadt sagt
zum beispiel amaretto benutzen denn
amaretto unterstützt so diesen marzipan
geschmack also durch die mandeln und
speckt denke ich ganz gut dazu jetzt
noch etwas speisestärke das berühre ich
jetzt klumpp ian fry und ich hab jetzt
sauerkirschen aus dem tiefkühlfach
genommen und habe die auftauen lassen
ihr könnt aber auch ganz frische
benutzen die in steinen und einfach die
benutzten
aber wir hatten gerade keine mehr jetzt
gebe ich auch direkt die kirchen mit
dazu weil die lassen auch so ein
bisschen wasser dann kann ich nämlich
alles zusammen aufkochen jetzt das ganze
kurz aufkochen
nach dem aufkochen nehmt jetzt den topf
vom herd herunter und lasst diese kirsch
füllung ein bisschen abkühlen
ich denke mal so etwa zehn minuten dann
dürfte so etwas langsam sein dann ist
auch der kuchen boden kalt und die
strecke habe ich auch ein kühlschrank
und gleich setzen wir dann den kuchen
zusammen
jetzt kann ich den kuchen zusammen
setzen und dafür streue ich jetzt dieses
paniermehl auf den teig das verhindert
einfach dass der teig so ein bisschen
durchweicht
dann kommt da die kühlung drauf
und dann verteidigt noch die streusel
drüber und wenn ihr merkt dass die
streusel ein bisschen zu feucht sind
gibt ja noch ein bisschen mehl mit rein
als ich ihn jetzt gerade das restliche
mehl was ich vorher noch übrig hatte von
also als den teig abgefragt ob es gerade
laufe und die verteidigte zäh so gut
rüber sie haben auch keine knusprigen
streusel sondern eher so gestresst
und jetzt wird der teig im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad für ungefähr 35
minuten gebacken
danach lasse ich ihn komplett auskühlen
und dann zeige ich euch wie ich
installieren
der kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt und ich
habe mir jetzt hier bereits süßen schnee
gerichtet denn ich werde den kuchen
jetzt damit bestäuben ihr könnt auch
puderzucker nehmen aber puderzucker
schwestern immer auf der oberfläche so
balz feucht wird oder auch wenn ich das
gebäck noch warm ist und dass wir so
schnell bleibt immer schön drauf legen
das sagt die wiener auch immer ich werde
jetzt die blumen bestäuben arbeit ist
bisschen aussieht als welches die frau
holle ich find das schneidern immer so
schön ist es nicht schön und ich habe
jetzt hier auch eine portion sahne
geschlagen
moore hat sich nämlich sahne dazu
gewünscht passt ja auch perfekt zu
seinem streuselkuchen so mit schneide
ich dir im stückler an
ich finde das sieht richtig gut aus und
ich glaube dir jetzt die sprache
verschlagen oder warum ist schüssel
hälse diabetes grüßen
aber es ist quatsch außerdem bekommt man
diabetes von zu viel zucker so ein
stückchen zum probieren
perfekt dazu würde jetzt natürlich ein
cappuccino passen locker
aber da wir ja ich mache den typischen
woche keine anderen kaffee und wie
schmeckt wirklich ja also wirklich
wichtig natürlich super also ich find
kirschen und marzipan passen sowieso
immer gut zusammen und ich denke dass
ich also ich denke die aromen passen
wirklich gut oder
ich habe es heute keine manila mit drin
weder ist auch das auch nicht so süß
dennoch nicht so süßlich ja das kommt
dadurch dass ich jetzt in der füllung
keine
keinen zusätzlichen zucker habt sondern
wirklich nur diesen marzipan brüssel
teig und diese marzipan streuseln die
süßen und innen drin sind dann die
sauerkirschen und ich denke es ergänzt
sich so ganz gut und ich finde sich ein
toller kuchen im winter kann man hier
noch immer abwandeln kann man gern noch
zur erfüllung etwas zimt mit dazugeben
passt auch ganz gut
oder einfach was eben einem noch so
einfällt und wenn ihr das rezept nach
machen wollt dann könnt ihr uns gerne
nachlesen auf service - blog.de morath
schmeckt matisse und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachbacken und wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
typisch
ich liebe mich auch hätte ist ja auch
immer diese marzipan wurscht es ist
super aber die zu weihnachten
warum dieser wurde es von verschiedenen
herstellern
von geheimen
nicht ab